any country that is predominantly
Islamic there is no freedom of religion
Christians Jews are persecuted
he's racing funds to establish a Masjid
and Community Center in Norway and they
urgently need your support this donation
will be a Saturday for you because every
person that comes a step closer to Allah
through your donation you and a child
American award click the link and donate
what you can
brothers and sisters and dear friends
foreign
you need to watch yourself and I think
something that's going to put hijab in
that reputation mood is the following
video are you ready I'm ready do you
know this guy no not that you need to no
there's nothing to know about anyways
yeah something Robinson yeah okay he
might be Tommy Robinson's uh brother
with the stuff that he says but hey here
we go buy this any culture that is
predominantly Islamic there is no
freedom of religion Christians Jews are
persecuted but any Christian country
people have freedom to worship whatever
God or is that a good treat to have or
is this weakness yes if we want to have
freedom freedom yeah Islam does not
provide freedom and like I say you can't
have a mutual there has to be a faith
and if there isn't one something else
steps in like wokeness if you go to
Israel and the way the Palestinians are
being treated that is not Freedom would
you say what do you mean the weather you
know this occluded in they they're
saying they're being prosecuted for
their religion really no no the problem
I mean this is
that's some majority Islamic area part
of the world right there's only one
country in that all in the whole area
where people are free that is Israel and
they don't like it and they don't like
Israel for it so they want to destroy it
one of those countries in that area
would you would you you have to go and
live in one of them which one would it
be I don't know yeah you do would you go
and live in Israel oh yeah I moved to
Tel Aviv or something like that it
sounds quite good there's only one
country in that whole of the Middle East
that I would live in oh sorry I didn't
think I thought you was excluded in
Israel you have to go to another one
yeah no it would be Israel of course it
would and that's why they hate it so in
a nutshell what do you make of there's
some speculations I find it very
interesting that towards the end I find
anybody who is unjust towards any kind
of faith it may be or specifically
towards Islam you can see that he
totally dismisses what the Palestinians
are going through and bear in mind there
are Palestinian Christians who have been
spattered who have been kicked out their
houses and he is there vocalizing that
he would want to go and live there yeah
these people would be spitting at you
and because you're a priest by their
Pastor or whatever you are point that to
a site is this historically correct that
number one Christians and Jews had no no
kind of Freedom that Islam is forced
would you make up well I mean the thing
is if this can be a historical
discussion or it can be a
contemporaneous one well one looks like
kind of like the Muslim countries and
stuff like that and looks at the
Christian countries of Muslim minorities
and vice versa and does a comparison
obviously one has to have a definition
of what they mean by tolerance but if
we're talking generally about someone
being able to which it seems like he is
talking about practice their religion if
we go back to the the facts that there
has been uh some of the most abominable
and condemnable acts in human history uh
where the opposite is happening in other
words where Christians have minorities
and that they are slaughtered they are
oppressed to a point where there's
almost historical if not there is
historical consensus of the matter and
this started from the very Beginnings or
first centuries of Christianity for
example when Constantine himself made
Christianity as a religion to State
religion in the fourth century and then
theodosius II actually encroached by
putting some laws some persecutory laws
in place is that if anyone doesn't even
just abide by certain tenants of
Christianity that those individuals will
be prosecuted then you have many many
examples in the upcoming centuries uh
prominent ones of course are the
Crusades
um what happened happened with Richard
the so-called Lionheart coming in and
historians talk about blood reaching the
knees of people slaughtering men women
and children and then you have of course
the Spanish Inquisition which is one of
the most violent uh events in human
history especially to Jewish people when
he talks about Ferdinand I mean this is
we're talking here around the time of
the was referred to as the reconquestia
so about 1492 and so this this is a time
where you know actually ironically
Jewish people were moving to Muslim
lands in the Ottoman Empire in
particular to seek Safe Haven from the
persecution of the Christians so this is
just some these are some examples and
obviously someone can counter and say
well what about them what about this
what about
we're not saying that Muslim dynasties
and countries have always been tolerant
to themselves and Muslim sects and other
sects but we're saying that this is this
crass and Hyper generalization it's not
an academic way of dealing with the
matter so that's the first thing if you
look at historically then if you're
talking about contemporaneously then
question first of all is what
constitutes as a Muslim country we're
talking about Muslim Islamic governance
because of the 60 Muslim majority
countries in some demographics how many
of them are claiming to even claiming to
rule by Quran Sunnah or the Sharia and
so on you'll find that it's not even a
handful of those countries maybe five if
you're lucky six that's not even 10 of
them the total number but if we talk
about 60 countries or 59 countries out
of 196 countries those countries that
have minorities in them yes so let's
take a look at the treatment for example
of Christians in Lebanon or let's take a
look at the treatment of Christians in
Egypt where I am originally from anyone
goes to Egypt and speaks to Ezekiel
Christians in Egypt and sees what kind
of Life they're living it's very very
difficult to make a case of Oppression
or persecute persecution is almost it's
almost an impossible case I mean they're
given they're given frankly they're
given extra provision yeah this is very
well known and anyone knows that they
give an extra provision and have been
for a very very long time actually and
Egypt as a whole as a country
historically even Thomas Walker Arnold
who wrote the preaching of Islam is an
orientalist and the book was published
first I think in late 1800s something
like that he's an orientalist and he
says when Islam spread to Egypt and
spreads other countries spread Islam to
Jerusalem yeah he made the point that
actually there was tolerance they
weren't allowed to practice their
religion so this this is spanning across
the whole time and the fact that that is
the case is the existence of the
corporate Christians there in the first
place everything Islam was completely
intolerant to these people why are they
existing in a in a Muslim majority
country for a thousand Four Hundred
Years of Islamic Rule and or majority
population so the the case is really
incoherent and for him to say that
Christianity has produced something
either contemporaneously or historically
which hasn't comparative to Islam is a
false argument I don't think he's gonna
be able to substantiate this um he would
have to write something peer-reviewed
and then people would have to the
academics would have to laugh at it
um and they would have to laugh at it I
mean any any honestly I mean this this
man is not making a convenient case at
all he's a joke man and Allah says in
the Quran very clearly that there is no
compulsion religion you know it's very
very clear and the funny thing is this
year I'll ask is there a simple question
to this man is that have you ever lived
in Islamic lands have you lived under
the caliphate which obviously you
wouldn't at this time well let's look at
some people who have lived let's see
what they had to say because you have no
damn experience so let's look at people
in history who did live there so we have
the chief Rabbi of Edna yeah which he
said here in the land of the Turks we
have nothing to complain of we possess
great fortunes much gold and silver in
our hands we are not oppressed with
heavy taxes and our Commerce is free and
unhindered Rich are the fruits of the
Earth everything is cheap and every one
of us live in Peace and Freedom here the
Jews are not compelled to wear a yellow
hat as a badge of Shame as this is the
case in Germany and that goes on so for
example let's go to quite a few more
here we've got Jews uh felt equally safe
in Jerusalem as confirmed by 9th century
Jewish Source Safa Petron Torah and this
is what he said the people in whose
hands the temple is today namely the
Muslims have made it into a choice
excellent and honorable place of worship
they say let us worship the one God who
created the heavens and the Earth to
whom the creatures belong until cometh
of the Messiah and on that day on that
day the true worship will be renewed and
we will accept that before god let's go
to for example Bernard the wise a
pilgrim monk visited Egypt and Palestine
in the reign of Khalifa
and a65 he stated the following the
Christian and the pagans inverted
Muslims pagans so he said the Christians
and the Muslims um have this kind of
peace between them that if if I was
going on a journey and on the way my
camon or donkey which bore my luggage
were todded meaning like maybe last year
and I was abundant of all my goods
without any guardian and I go to the
city for another pack of animal when I
came back I would for I would find all
my property uninjured such is the piece
that and look look at this I mean I I
like this point you just made the final
book because actually the Golden Age of
Islam yes this is this obviously is our
best period martussin was one of the
adverted um caliphs and in the Golden
Age of Islam some of the greatest names
in for example Islamic Jewish and
Christian history existed in Islamic
rule so for example the most prominent
Jewish example is maimonidis which is
yes he wrote very many books
in Arabic funny enough it's called the
god of the perplexed it's one of the
most well-known words is he seen as the
second Moses officer second Moses yeah
so I mean he's a good I mean this is one
great example of his seat is one of the
the biggest name in Chris in Judaism and
he existed in the time or in Spanish
Spanish Muslim lands at that time so
here's one example in the translation
movement a lot of the people who were
Christian Arabs at the time yeah they
were allowed to produce Works in that
burst periods and they were allowed to
produce Works they were fraternizing um
they had high run positions
absolutely I mean all of these kind of
things I was so it's this is a very
difficult case to make for him once
again I think it's either you just want
to make a statement that gets you
um maybe you're just an ignorant person
yeah I think it just has a lot of
history I think it just has a lot of
hatred I'll be honest with his name and
Robinson and he speaks like Tommy
Robinson for that matter just finished
on this Tommy Robinson actually makes a
more compelling case yeah you can say
exactly yeah and now just another Jewish
person Sammy Cohen he said we want to
see we want to send the world a message
that we have been living here peacefully
for centuries while other Jewish
communities have suffered in Many Lands
of Europe you Christians have been the
ones that have been persecuting the
Jewish people for years on end because
they you didn't they killed your god
look there's many examples I can give in
history yeah the math is clear number
one two not even know the basic
principle in Islam that there is no
compulsion in religion it just shows me
what kind of an ignoramus cheers
look let me tell you something yeah yeah
you know I wish she had more intellect
as big as your hair okay
as much as hey you had your intellect
inside your brain inside your head
rather than outside of it yeah
that's what it is
to be said it just shows that his
intellectually corrupt bankrupt um
molested I think I'm gonna end on that
no it's a pleasure as always
sisters please send this video to this
man directly from me inshallah he
doesn't need to see it he doesn't need
to see it I mean who
he's a nobody if he sees it if he
doesn't let me ask a question okay
okay he doesn't see it
I mean if he sees it if he doesn't see
it yeah if he's happy if he's sad yeah
listen if he's over the Earth if he's
under the Earth what difference will it
make to humanity I can give this example
if he's over there I can give this
example if he's under the Earth it's
like what the difference it's like it's
like my good friend zeeshan passing wind
he has nowhere listen it just doesn't
have no impact it's just it was just
winning he just do this and do you carry
on your day hand waiver until next time